my name is rose george and i am an
author and journalist and i am
fascinated by blood and here's why
[Music]
we are stardust and seawater the iron in
our blood comes from the death of
supernovas like all iron on our planet
and it contains salt and water like the
oceans we came from
the circulatory system of veins arteries
and capillaries is about a hundred
thousand kilometers long twice the
circumference of the earth
[Music]
most of that is the capillaries tiny
blood vessels and holloways that reach
nearly every cell in the body you may
know that your blood is a b o or a b but
there are other types you may not have
heard of including duffy
kid
okay
and the epically named landsteiner vena
animals have blood types too dogs have
eight cats have three when humans first
tried to transfer blood between bodies
they used the blood of a lamb and a calf
now we stick to carefully chosen human
blood blood transfusion is so common
every three seconds worldwide someone
receives a stranger's blood
we don't have the same supply sloshing
around our veins all our lives our blood
is in a constant state of decay and
renewal red blood cells live in our body
for about 143 days decanted into a blood
bag they have a shelf life of between 35
and 49 days blood lasts longer than milk
but not as long as cheese in a resting
human the heart pumps a liter of blood
every 10 seconds and it beats on average
75 times a minute a blue whale's heart
the size of a small car beats five times
a minute and less on deep dives
a shrews a thousand times a minute the
average human contains eight to twelve
pints of blood but can usually survive
losing up to 40 percent after that point
the organs begin to shut down because
they are not being fed oxygen by blood
blood has always been thought powerful
the mythical figure of medusa symbolized
human fear and ore of blood blood from
the right side of her body was fatal
while that from the left side could
restore life we may not believe in greek
myths anymore but the force of blood
remains in language
blood brothers blood feud bloodlines
blood is essential for human life but
there is still plenty we don't know
about this exceptional substance
scientists can now grow red blood cells
in the lab but they are extremely
expensive
for now the only way to get this
life-saving life enhancing liquid is out
of the goodness of someone's heart
and the veins in their arm
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video